three mile strip for the future a
monorail to connect hotels on las vegas
boulevard and the convention center
however the monorail here in town has
been in and out of bankruptcy for years
and today it is closed by the
coronavirus
but it might have a new owner bianca
holman is live this afternoon with new
details bianca
good afternoon john when it's running
the monorail system here in las vegas
gives up to 5 million rides per year
today clark county commissioners agreed
on a plan for the lvcva to buy the
shuttered system with hopes of
finally making it profitable the lvcva
wants to buy the monorail system for
24.2 million dollars
the plan is to work with the corporation
in a bankruptcy filing
covert has forced the company to shut
down the system and it hasn't made money
in several months but the bankruptcy
filing would be part of a long-term
solution for the monorail
lbcva ceo steve hill says and also
says the authority can make the line
more efficient
we feel like we have the opportunity
to operate the system more efficiently
simply
because of who we are we have the
ability to borrow money at a
significantly lesser
interest rate we have office space they
are currently
leasing office space
a 10-year non-compete clause around the
monorail is about to expire
hill says it would take 200 million
dollars to replace the train so within
the next decade hill believes that
this is the time to look into a system
that could replace the monorail system
when it becomes obsolete now that is
approved by the clark county
commissioners
it is now time for the lvcba to agree on
the proposal and they have a meeting
that will be taking place later on this
afternoon
reporting live from near paradise and
convention center drive bianca holman 8
news now